voi ragazzi lo sapete che io sono un po
spericolato non è che quindi vivo la mia
vita un po al limite cioè faccio cose
estreme
[Musica]
calori già mamma bene lo sai che non ho
mangiato a pranzo oggi ecco quest'ultima
è stata decisamente estrema comunque
ragazzi allora siamo qui oggi perché
avanzi tutto prendiamo questo video
bello perché sono un cazzo l a tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video sono
file dei ed oggi siamo tornati su un
nuovo blog che non è un blog ma è una
cosa un po più michael bublè io e anche
rai med
dunque che chi ha partecipato al
programma di social face abbiamo dovuto
accettare un contratto nou dove sapete
quando scorrete le liste di per cui
scrivete i siti porno tanto lo sappiamo
tutti che vi scrive dei siti quindi la
samp prima di iscrivervi c'è tutto quel
po po di roba che voi andateci si va
bene acconsento al conoscente poi vi
iscrivete ok quando ho firmato un
contratto lavorativo quindi in questo
caso tipo di social face firmare un
contratto sarebbe la stessa cosa cioè
nel senso vai su ok e firmi
ecco nel contratto di social face c'era
scritto che davamo la nostra
disponibilità per fare delle cose delle
cose le penitenze che con i social face
mente sono randomiche quindi ogni
persona che tira la ruota alla fine può
uscir liotti di spalmare nuovi faccia
oppure ti devi buttare da un ponte di
150 metri e indovinate un po tra l'uomo
e il ponte di 150 metri cosa cazzo mi è
uscito a metà non avevo dubbi comunque
ragazzi miei sono orgoglioso oggi di
essere vivo soprattutto ma a parte
questo di annunciarvi che motivo e
magari non lo sanno però il suo social
facebook è andata in onda la puntata ho
dovuto fare una penitenza ovvero
buttarmi da un ponte di 150 metri col
bungee jumping
kakà ha data il prossimo con la tua
faccia in mezzo a parte sta stronzata
megagalattica vi lascio al video visto
che ho parlato fin troppo godetevelo
almeno voi
guarda qartetto guarda ha scritto salire
sulle grate ma lo sai questo rumore era
allora siamo in alto evidenza questa è
una penitente aspettavano le verità di
chi butta ricordo la città per una cosa
non ti invidio maremma maiala tutto
mezzo che la pista è che giocando così
si fuori cioè di concludere un 152 metri
di vuoto
8 io abito al terzo piano c'è il
problema maremma a guardare giù
l'ultimo guardare lo guardo io giù ad un
caso ma io sono tutto capace di meno
tempo affetti meglio è finita qui
rea è assurdo non ci sto facendo no
ragazzi io non c'erano meno tempo fa
benissimo lì cosa presto comincerò soli
vai su milioni ma vai così fanno male se
vieni avanti piano piano viene ritrovata
la luna non fa nulla hanno piano con i
piedi piano piano con i piedi ancora
avanti ancoranti perfetto così alla
cappella le braccia ogni volta noi che
contiamo
ora
mancino
[Musica]
il fatto assurdo perché quando nel
momento in cui non si tende la corda e
tipo la sensazione di volare e del
denaro va sondaggisti sentiti pò goku
quando vola una roba incredibile
vabbè è stato figo sono stato un super
sayan per 5 secondi
quindi ragazzi e allora il fatto è che
molti di voi mi chiedi mi hanno chiesto
dopo la puntata di social face me lo
chiedete anche qui sotto quindi faccio
prima a rispondere già che cosa si prova
quando ci si lancia nel vuoto questa
cosa è anche col paracadute è successo
entrambe le volte sia col paracadute che
col banchi jumping marco al bungee
jumping di più buttarsi nel vuoto e
attraversare l'aria tipo superman con
molti meno muscoli strano non lo so
spiegare una sensazione stranissima non
riuscite a capire un cazzo perché a
parte e vi state cagando addosso che
pregate i bio che la corda non si spezza
per ho visto la mia massa muscolare mi
sa che mi spezzo prima io punto 2 avete
tutta l'adrenalina in corpo e quindi non
capito un cazzo neanche per quel punto
numero tre sentite l'aria nelle orecchie
che soffia fortissimo come se avesse
dico messo un amico vi soffiasse forte
nell'orecchio e tutte queste cose messe
insieme non vi fanno capire un cazzo la
seconda domanda che mi ha fatto anche
mia nonna quando ho saputo che ho fatto
baggi jumping è stata che cosa succede
dopo the ritirano su o ti tirano giù e
questa cosa ma sono chiesto anch'io fino
a un secondo prima di buttarmi in realtà
alla fine ti tirano giù ed è una merda
parte quando si tende alla corda la
prima volta poi tornate su velocissimi
io credevo di morire non più per lo
schianto per terra da quanto per lo
schianto sul ponte gradevoli di tornare
su sul ponte di sbatte all'attesa
fortissima quando rimbalzate due o tre
volte che poi vi fermate ed altro non so
se si è visto ma sono accaduto di un
bene che ho iniziato a roteare manco
fosse un beyblade vai tutta capacità
artistica che ciò io succede che
rimanete appesi a penzoloni a mezz'aria
e questa è una merda perché volete che
finisca tutto prima possibile invece
siete così attaccati a staccarsi ricorda
da 12.000 metri che guardate a testa in
giù un burrone di 70 metri e non potete
fare un cazzo ed è orribile vi giuro che
orribile poi carano giunti prende un
tizio
ti mette in salvo e da lì poi c'è la
[ __ ] per tutta la vita ma io ce l'avevo
già con just dance quindi non mi è
servito a un pen
ovviamente questa roba l'ho detto ai
miei genitori solo dopo averla fatta
perché se la mia madre sarebbe morta
d'infarto ronca ragazzi questo tutto sto
casino e per dirvi che quando cercate di
iscrivervi ai siti che parte acconsento
al consenso acconsento fate attenzione
che nelle postille non ci sia scritto
cliccando acconsento ti dovrai buttare
da un ponte di 150 metri ecco
controllate che non ci sia scritto quel
e siamo a posto
ragazzi miei questo era un video un po
più corto del solito ma dovevo dedicarci
assolutamente un blog a questa roba
perché dio mio già che ci ha avuto
l'infarto almeno un video su stacca
cartacea rado tira fuori santo iddio
almeno quello spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi cose in semi la visione sul
commento è un mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook che coniughi loro tornare
iscrizione sensi di siete vicini mediano
prossimo video bene ragazzi social face
sufi lunedì e giovedì alle 19 25 solo su
sky uno